bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
émission spéciale ce soir sur la crise
du coronavirus à 20 heures vous allez
pouvoir suivre en direct l'allocution du
président de la république depuis
l'elysée d'ici là où va revenir sur les
principales informations de la journée
le chef de l'état qui a envisagé le
report des élections municipales il a
consulté les présidents des deux
chambres
aujourd'hui on verra ce qu'il en est de
cette décision dans son discours en
attendant l'union sacrée entre les
principaux chefs de partis politiques a
volé en éclats toutes les oppositions
réclament des mesures économiques et
sociales à la hauteur certains veulent
même une pause dans les réformes
on en parlera on évoquera aussi la
décision choc de donald trump le
président américain suspens l'ensemble
des vols en provenance de l'union
européenne bruxelles condamne cette
mesure fait s'écrouler les marchés
financiers est elle efficace
on en parlera et puis on s'interrogera
sur la manière dont les chefs d'état
s'exprime sur cette crise le discours
d'angela merkel a suscité beaucoup de
réactions la chancelière assume de dire
aux allemands que deux tiers de son
peuple sera infecté voilà donc pour le
programme de ce savon garde spéciale
c'est parti on y va
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
dans une demi heure exactement on suivra
un ensemble de discours d' emmanuel
macron c'est sa première adresse aux
français depuis le début de la crise
bonsoir bruno keitel et merci d'être
avec nous en direct vous êtes député la
république en marche de leur carole
barjon bienvenus vous êtes journaliste
éditorialiste politique à l'ops et jacky
isabello bienvenue à vous vous êtes
communiquant cofondateur de l'agencé
corio link je vous donne la parole dans
un instant mais d'abord si j'ai bien
compris l'union sacrée c'est terminé
stéphane blakowski 7,8 bonsoir à toutes
et tous bonsoir des fans si j'ai bien
compris ce soir et ben si j'ai bien
compris
myriem alors certes l'épidémie de
coronavirus est loin d'être terminé mais
on se sent quand même un début de retour
à la normale sur le plan économique
évidemment puisque la sorte que les
entreprises en plus en plus recours au
chômage technique pas non plus au plan
sanitaire puisque on s'attend à passer
au stade 3 de l'épidémie mais mais il ya
du retard la normale c'est dans le
domaine politique
oui alors là oui j'ai l'impression que
oui on est revenu à la normal parce que
le virus va peut-être tomber l'économie
ne souhaite pas il va peut-être saturer
le système de santé mais il n'aura pas
la peau de notre vie politique
il ya une trêve c'était il ya quinze
jours à l'époque tout le monde sauf
marine le pen avait mis de côté les
divergences avec le gouvernement et on
disait en avant l'unité nationale en
écoute un exemple bruno retailleau
mais pas question d'utiliser ce risque
là pour faire de la politique
politicienne je pense qu'il ya un besoin
d'unité nationale et l or on est en
quinze jours plus tard alors rien que je
ne sais pas si vous êtes déjà essayé
d'arrêter de fumer
voilà quel point celle dans l'opposition
arrêtez de critiquer le gouvernement
c'est encore plus compliqué que
d'arrêter de fumer
d'ailleurs il n'a qu' il n'y arrive pas
en marine le pen par exemple passer une
journée sans critiquer les gouvernants
c'est carrément au sud s'efforcent donc
il avait déjà pris ses distances ya
quinze jours évidemment l'on remet une
couche ce matin ce soir le président va
j'imagine tenter de nous rassurer par
rapport à l'épidémie
elle dit exactement contraire il n'y a
pas de quoi être rassuré on écoute on ne
peut pas demander aux français
encore une fois d'adopter un certain
nombre de comportements si par ailleurs
on leur explique que c'est rien du tout
que c'est comme la grippe a
ça n'est pas comme la grippe c'est clair
maintenant je crois en tout cas c'est ce
qui est dit et ceux qui ont cherché à
minimiser la situation depuis le début
commence à rétropédaler
donc si on veut que les français adopte
effectivement des mesures encore faut-il
qu'ils comprennent que ce n'est pas à
nous d'en bas sauf que aujourd'hui la
seule marine le pen a critiqué et
l'allemagne en selle elle critique la
gestion sanitaire de la crise elle est
la seule jusqu'à présent l'opposition le
reste qui s'inquiètent plutôt pour les
guérir le thème de l'économie ou le
thème social par exemple ce matin damien
abad qui est le président du groupe est
là à l'assemblée sur rfi lui
s'inquiétait à l'idée que le gardien
n'en fasse pas assez pour les
entreprises on écoute
il nous faut créer un régime
d'indemnisation d'état qui permettent
tout simplement
et bien par le budget de l'état de
financer toutes les entreprises qui vont
perdre parce qu'il ya eu des annulations
d'événements parce qu'il ya des défauts
livraison pas ce qui est des ruptures de
chant l'aïe un joue un rôle de l'état
alors ça c'est le retour à la normale
dans que l'opposition s'oppose le
gouvernement de son côté dit mais
pourquoi vous opposez-vous puisqu'on a
tout prévu
réponse de bruno le maire aux
républicains nous allons étudier la mise
en place d'un fonds de solidarité pour
les entreprises qui seraient les plus
impactés par le choc économique
je souhaite simplement que ce fonds
solidarité soit vraiment réservé aux
entreprises qui sont les plus petites
les plus modestes qui sont à court de
trésorerie qui n'ont pas d'autres moyens
que de faire après la seconde solidarité
ça c'est pour les entreprises cette
crise
elle a aussi des conséquences sociales
et voilà est donc là évidemment c'est
plutôt la gauche qui est sensible à cet
aspect donc qui montent au créneau avec
les syndicats les syndicats disent il ya
une réforme on va mettre en oeuvre la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
ça va peser sur les plus précaires il
faut reporter ça parce que justement
c'est ce qu'ils sont plus exposés aux
conséquences économiques et donc social
de la crise et olivier fortier du ps il
a repris le mot d'ordre des syndicats ce
matin quand on voit la crise pétrolière
qui s'annonce quand on voit la crise
financière et bien moi je souhaite que
ceux celles et ceux qui vont tomber au
chômage et bien n'ait pas à subir les
conséquences de restrictions qui sont
tout ce qui était déjà folle il y a
quelques mois et qui deviennent
inconséquente
aujourd'hui évidemment muriel pénicaud
elle l aime bien sa réforme l'assurance
chômage
donc avant de la changer elle aimerait
bien savoir qui a pas d'autre option
c'est ce qu'elle dit ce matin on va
faire quelque chose on va voir on est en
train de regarder comment faire on n'a
pas attendu les organisations syndicales
pourraient travailler ça fait plusieurs
jours qu'on travaille à plusieurs
options
donc on va enfin faire quelque chose
c'est trop tôt ce matin pour le dire
nous voyons là fait le tour de tout le
monde tout on a pu parler le
gouvernement l'opposition on sent bien
qu'il se dise cette idée d'unité
nationale des quinze jours se fendit là
où elle pourrait carrément explosé c'est
si toutefois il y avait un report des
municipales donc pour l'instant ce n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour mais on en parle
beaucoup on en parle tellement que on se
demande si le président ne doit pas
l'annoncer tout à l'heure et là
évidemment plus d'unité nationale
puisque les républicains on endure des
détresses à ont remonté pour ce que tu
un casus belli pour merci merci stéphane
c'est une information du jdd un qui
révélait que le président envisageait et
chaque mot compte ce report des
élections municipales l'information que
s&p a pu se faire confirmer à envisager
ono qu'était déjà sur les municipales on
va on va parler du reste bien sûr mais
est il raisonnable franchement de
maintenir ces élections il ya un premier
tour dimanche mais il ya aussi un second
tour c'est dans dix jours
notre dose semaine passée le 23 15 au 22
mars 2 donc est ce que est ce que c'est
raisonnable franchement dans cette
période alors qu'une partie du monde se
barricade et je sais pas s'il a raison
doit être le maître mot de notre
réflexion collective
je veux dire par là que les élections
elles sont effectivement inscrits les 15
et 22 mars
je ne sais pas le sans fil dans dix
jours à nouveau j'ai panonceau norisko
de la star des français dans les bureaux
de vote salut dans les bureaux de vote
il ya rarement plus de cinquante ou
soixante quinze personnes qui sont les
unes derrière les autres à 1 mètres
d'intervalle
je veux dire il faut aussi aux desserrer
un peu l'étau sur cette fois de psychose
cette forme pas bon de psychose
collective qui est un peu entretenues
enfin mise en place et entretenu
président de la république va s'exprimer
à 20h on le trouvait qu'on en fait trop
et une tribune des journalistes qui sont
correspondant en italie journalistes
français qui disent réveillez vous
regardez la situation
ce pont de lattes et aurait dit l'ancien
ministre
parce que j'étais à l'échappée l'italie
la france ne sont pas tout à fait je
dirais sur un même plan soit à la fois
d'organisations politiques
administratives et sociales et de santé
ça c'est un premier point enfin
président de la république va s'exprimer
tout à l'heure ça a été rappelée à 20
heures donc moi je vais pas vous dire il
faut il faut pas je suis un député de la
majorité je vais écouter le président de
la république au même titre que chacune
et chacun et je me plierai aux décisions
le cas échéant qu'il prendra mais je
crains que vous ne le souhaitez pas vous
ne souhaitez pas si de rien ce report
vous mêmes députés l'attendait vous n'en
voulez hein je n'attends rien je vais
voir ce que le président de la
république va faire je suis député de la
majorité je vais me conformer les
orientations le cas échéant clinique il
déclinera mais je crains pour la presse
et cette forme de microcosme qui ne se
dissimule pas surtout en période de
tension comme cela vous soyez déçu ou
essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
je vous donne la parole dans un instant
el hanout a rejoint les amendes un gala
de la rédaction de lcp qu'est ce qui se
passe en coulisses alors en coulisses
pour l'instant à mettre beaucoup de
conditionnel sur ce qu'on dit puisque on
al impression qu effectivement rien
n'est tranché il ya un homme qui sait ce
qui va se passer c'est emmanuel macron
il va parler à 20 heures il est le seul
à savoir exactement ce qui va dire plus
dire effectivement ce qu'on est en
mesure de confirmer c'est qu'après avoir
répété pendant plusieurs jours qu'il
fallait que la démocratie continue que
les élections se tiennent
il y a eu le scénario du report qui a
été envisagée par l'elysée
on a essayé de voir comment on pouvait
faire il faut un décret mais après il
faut une loi
ce qui nécessite donc un consensus des
différents partis de gouvernement
et on sait que la droite elle est montée
au créneau françois baroin le directeur
de l'association des maires de france
devant gérard larcher président du sénat
christian jacob président des
républicains
pour eux le report des municipales c'est
un casus belli ils n'en veulent
absolument pas on sait donc que cette
scénario est évoquée pourquoi il ya eu
cela ne veut pas dire et je vous vois le
vélib l'annoncé ce soir mais je suis
fait pas c'est parce que les
républicains ont en tout cas qu'un
report envisagé c'est une information
est là on explique pourquoi alors que
c'était absolument pas à l'ordre du jour
alors qu est ce qui a accéléré la
décision la situation en italie
évidemment anguila merkel en allemagne
qui prend la situation très au sérieux
les bourses qui dévisse des spécialistes
eric comme par exemple le chef du
service des maladies infectieuses de la
salpêtrière qui est très pessimiste hier
sur lci par exemple donc effectivement
on s'est posé la question de savoir s'il
fallait ou non déplacée ces élections
carole barjon qu'est ce que ça dit même
si le président de la république
n'annonce pas ce report tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que ça dit du climat là haut
sommet de l'état
déjà qu est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça dit
qu'il est éventuellement en za du mans
bon c'est très étrange parce que ça fait
quand même maintenant plusieurs semaines
que le gouvernement se montre c'est
rassurant malgré des alertes et même des
cris d'alarmé de gens comme le
professeur comme qui s'est fait quand
même renvoyé dans les cordes
assez méchamment derrière d'après ce que
je sais en coulisses par
le gouvernement parmi la santé par mâcon
lui même puisqu'il y avait une règle est
permis de douter fortement de la gestion
et les décisions prises par ouï
gouvernement oui et on met plus de
mesures fortes et sûres notamment de
confinement biais d'être à la remise de
vouloir affoler les populations
bon donc pourquoi est-ce que tout d'un
coup emmanuel macron aurait aujourd'hui
décidé d'écouter ces gens là c'est ça
qu'on a du mal à comprendre si jamais il
prenait la décision de reporter les
municipales parce que ça voudrait dire
que du coup ils écoutent ce qu'on
qualifiait d' alarmiste il ya encore et
encore la semaine dernière si vous
voulez donc ça c'est bizarre par
ailleurs si jamais les îles annoncé le
report des municipales il faut qu'il y
ait d'autres mesures en cohérence avec
cette décision c'est à dire on a
fermeture des écoles on ferme les écoles
parce qu'il n'y a pas sinon il n'y a pas
de raison l'opposition n'a pas tort de
souligner et c'est ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure
qu après tout une files d'attentes dans
comment dire dans un bureau de vote
c'est pas pire que une file d'attende
dans un supermarché et donc qu'il faudra
au moins que les mesures sont en
cohérence
oui jacques isabello vous êtes
communiquant chaque mot va compter ce
soir il s'agit de rassurer et il s'agit
aussi au fond on sent bien alors qu'on
voit que l'italie voilà est vraiment
dans une forme de cauchemars là dans les
hôpitaux notamment et on a exactement la
même courbe un peu spécieux superposés
en termes de rapidité prend de
propagation il s'agit de faire quoi de
rassurer et en même temps de donner aux
français des mesures fortes qu'ils
attendent
il ne peut pas se contenter simplement
de pédagogie expliquer aux gens qui nous
écoutent qu' on est dans l'avant match
mais que votre métier à vous c'est pas
de dire tout et n'importe quoi le jdd
est un grand journal david rondeau
revault d'allonnes et enseignants c'est
vraiment et l'informé quand il a cette
information et qu'il l'a confirmé il
faut le dire aux gens il a eu quelqu'un
de l'elysée donc cet avant match il est
important donc si quelqu'un de l'elysée
décide de lui donner cette information
est que vous vous la fait confirmer
politiquement c'est important puisque on
le met dans l'espace public ont fait pas
comme ça en disant tiens rocheteau va
revenir il va remettre les crampons
donc il faut expliquer aux gens que ça
fait partie de la communication du
gouvernement est évidemment
diplômée de journalisme c'est pas parce
que je vous dis un truc sur la manière
dont on l'a propulsé une compagnie que
vous allez même accorder de la
crédibilité donc ça c'est quand même
important ce temps de communication
il est essentiel dans cette crise et
pourquoi il est essentiel dans cette
crise parce que ce qui est insupportable
dans ces situations et l' oms l'ext
l'expliquent extrêmement bien dans ces
documents
c'est que nous vivons quelque chose dans
ces sociétés organisées que nous ne
sommes pas prêts à faire c'est à dire de
gérer l'incertitude l'om s10 première
étape confiance on a confiance en les
parlementaires les journalistes dans
l'ensemble même si les études du cevipof
disent tout un tas de choses
deuxième chose il reposer vous sur les
communautés deux professionnels les
médecins même s'ils disent pas tous la
même chose on a quand même confiance la
troisième chose il nous dit dans dans
vos sociétés morgen moderne de la
mondialisation vous ne savez pas gérer
l'incertitude quand jérôme salomon alors
qu'on lui accorde notre confort dire là
dessus je ne sais pas donc cet aspect
d'incertitude et bien lui il doit être
contrebalancé par une figure du chef qui
a une posture militaire qui adopte comme
disait chirac
l'attitude de celui qui va chez fait
donc il faut qu'il parle de méthodes il
faut qu'il soit extrêmement présent et
il faut qu'ils embarquent l'ensemble du
pays et qu'ils aient des temps de
communication qui permettent à couvrir
ses coordonnées et ce temps de
communication ce soit il est fait pour
ça si jamais le président de la
république prend la parole pour ne rien
dire
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va de ne
rien dire via veut dire quoi il faut des
mesures où il faut de de la méthode pour
gérer ce n'est pas l'analyse sexy vous
avez appelé l'élysée s'il jdd s'est fait
confirmer cette information c'est que ce
soit il va y avoir des annonces
importantes qu'elles soient politiques
qu'elles soient sanitaire qu'elle soit
par rapport à tout un tas d'autres
engagements mais on doit satisfaire
l'opinion publique c'est essentiel sinon
on permet au président de la république
de créer de la distorsion de la
dissonance cognitive
donc moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que sans doute ce soir si le principal
chef de l'état qui va se substituer à
l'ensemble des corps constitués prend
la parole c'est pour quelque chose
deuxième information que je veux la paix
revenant à d'évoquer le jdd parle de
l'utilisation de l'article 16
dans son cas on n'est pas la forclaz sel
c'est la bombe nucléaire et plein si
jamais le président de la république
décidé que pour un extrêmement vite il a
besoin de coordonner faute de revoir les
lois au parlement parce que j'ai
seulement dans cette terre sous le
contrôle du conseil constitutionnel
parce que depuis 2008 le conseil
constitutionnel quand même regarde
whisky sont alors encore viser moins
haut mais moi j'avais accès remonter ce
que dit votre confrère non mais ce que
je veux dire c'est jean pierre roth
parce que je voudrais mais jamais je
n'ai pas dit avant de mesurer ce que
peuvent dire les journées je sais
traminots ce fut aussi à l'art et en
soit il ya la parole du président de la
république
on va on va l'écouter il n'aurait la
pire chose qui n'a rien à voir avec la
qualité des journalistes dont vous
parlez c'est simplement que le président
se soit quoi qu'il annonce
il faut puisqu'il s'agit quand même
d'inspirer confiance au pays évidemment
et bien dans ce cas là il faut que ce
qu'il dit ce soir soit en cohérence avec
ce qui a été dit et fait auparavant
parce que sinon on vient on parlera de
retard à l'allumage et de panique
soudaine faut de la continuité et la
part de la cohérence
allez on parle de donald trump en
attendant la locution depuis l'elysée de
d'emmanuel macro c'est donc une mesure
choc qu'a prise le président américain
il a suspendu tous les vols en
provenance de l'union européenne
explications réactions ahmed tazir il
l'avait longtemps relativiser désormais
donald trump rend la mesure de la menace
coronavirus depuis son bureau de la
maison blanche le président américain
mais l'europe en quarantaine le cas pour
empêcher de nouveaux cas de pénétrer
dans notre pays nous allons suspendre
tous les voyages en provenance d'europe
vers les états unis pour les 30
prochains jours
les nouvelles réglementations prendront
effet vendredi à minuit
le président américain ferme son pays
aux ressortissants de l'espace schengen
mais par les britanniques
aussitôt plongeon de 10% la bourse de
londres -2 12% pour la bourse de paris
la plus forte chute de son histoire
prise de court l'union européenne
désapprouve la décision unilatérale du
président américain
avons nous reçu des informations des
états unis avant l' annonce certainement
pas puisque c'est pour ça que nous nous
regrettons et nous marquons notre
désaccord avec la manière dont cette
décision a été prise en france le
secrétaire d'état aux transports
appellent à une coordination européenne
pour évaluer la décision de donald trump
je connais le tempérament de donald
trump qui a réagit d'ailleurs peut-être
un peu plus tard que certains autres
pays notamment les pays européens sur le
sujet il prend aujourd'hui des mesures
assez drastiques sur l'espace schengen
que nous aurons évidemment à évaluer et
je le redis ça nécessite d'autant plus
la coordination européenne autour du
président de la république qui comme
vous le savez a pris le leadership
européen en termes à la fois des mesures
de soutien et des mesures de
coordination de manière à trouver les
bons équilibres a passé ses deux trois
semaines qui sont devant nous qui
correspondront possiblement au pic
épidémique et puis surtout à se
repositionner dans l'après coronavirus
l'italie a dépassé le cap des 1000 morts
le pays durci sa politique de
confinement en fermant la plupart des
commerces non alimentaires
nous fermons les magasins les bars les
pubs et les restaurants et nous laissons
la possibilité de faire des livraisons à
domicile de nos seniors la chancelière
allemande n'y est pas allé par quatre
chemins et paul et de son ministre de la
santé en gala merkel a prévenu que près
de 58 millions de ses compatriotes
peuvent être touchées par la maladie
s'il n'y a pas de vaccin prêtes à mosman
fast enough
il faut comprendre que si le virus est
présent et que la population n'est pas
encore immunisés contre lui et qu'il
n'existe pas de possibilité de
vaccination ni de traitement alors un
pourcentage élevé de la population
les experts 10 60 à 70 % sera infecté
tant que cette situation persiste
si la touche tab life un monde qui
s'enferme face à la pandémie et une note
positive qui nous vient de chine
là bas le nombre de nouvelles
contaminations aux coville 19 continuent
de chuter
aujourd'hui seulement quinze cas ont été
recensés et j'accueille avec plaisir
françois durpaire bonsoir êtes notre
spécialiste des états unis n'ont rien
qu'est ce qui a poussé donald trump à
une telle décision
ouais c'est en ce moment un petit peu là
que dans trente trois semaines sont les
élections aux états unis donc là c'est
un peu la course à l'échalote protège le
mieux les américains donc on est sur une
chaîne parlementaire commençant par le
congrès d'un mot les démocrates disent
on va protéger à mettre des milliards de
dollars pour par exemple donner des
tests gratuits puis les républicains
disent non non non vous essayez de faire
de la politique et des largeurs les
politiques santé et 30 17 nuits ce que
les américains veulent entendre
on ferme les frontières on se protège du
reste du monde il avait dit à quelques
heures plus tôt on a tous les tests
c'est juste une grille plaira il essaye
un peu de se racheter de ses propos dans
son lait vient même byden dont on disait
que son adversaire probable donc on me
disait que c'était un candidat un peu
fébrile retrouve du poil de la bête sur
le thème mois avec moi à la maison
blanche ce sera un monde stable
un monde où vous serez protégé il a
trouvé cet argument là alors qu'est ce
que vous pouvez faire confiance à ce
protecteur en chef le mercredi qui vous
disaient le mardi qu'il fallait
absolument pas s'inquiéter de ce qui
était vraiment pas du tout grave mais
les américains s'inquiètent aussi de
quelque chose et donald trump a parlé
effectivement de cette interdiction des
européens sur le territoire américain il
a aussi beaucoup parlé d'économie
parce que évidemment si l'économie ces
fonds et c'est vraiment le grand
problème aujourd'hui aux états unis
certes dans le monde 4389 mort mais
combien de millions de gens ruinés
il y aura en tout cas beaucoup plus
dormi n'est que de morts et ça c'est une
évidence les pme privé aux etats-unis de
leur chaîne faut quand même rappeler que
la chine c'est quand même un tiers de la
production mondiale c'est le premier
exportateur donc tout son protégé
repris à comparer aux tripes pascal a
raison peut-être il faut surtout
protéger l'économie américaine d'un
risque de récession avec l'auto
isolement c'est pas 2008 où il ya la
crise financière c'est l'auto isolement
c'est se fermer et là c'est évidemment
renforcé les risque bien de ne pas
pouvoir résoudre les problèmes qu est ce
que vous pensez de cette décision donald
trump je vais vous citer un tweet de
jean pierre raffarin qui écrit ceci
aujourd'hui merci à donald trump pour sa
fidélité à l'amitié euro atlantique avec
des amis comme ça on est en toute
sécurité
c'est de l'humour avec des amis comme ça
on n'a pas besoin d'ennemis exactement à
quoi je pensais vous avez raison un truc
tout bête perso ma fille est partie en
angleterre ce soir pour quatre jours
elle m'a donné une procuration pour les
municipales et je vous rassure parce que
j'irai voter dimanche
mais je trouve tout cela est
profondément stupide et de la part du
président des états unis nous ramène
finalement repli sur soi de quelques
états désigne nouvelle donald trump est
dans son rôle il est en campagne je vous
le rappelle quand même accessoirement il
est dans son rôle de stigmatiser le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne de
mettre à mal toute perspective d'union
de celle ci dans le contexte que vous
évoquez ce soir et lui il n'a qu'une
ambition et qu'une intention c'est de
fragiliser le collectif qui nous
rassemble depuis 1945 avec isabelle aux
cancans françois dit au fond il dit au
peuple ce qu'il veut entendre c'est le
propre des dictateurs et on sait qu'ils
parlent en premier lieu également à sa
communauté parce que c'est quand même
donald trump il a la spécificité d'être
l'homme politique qui a le plus de gens
connectés à lui par l'intermédiaire de
ses réseaux sociaux moi je pense qu'il
ya un autre point aussi à prendre en
compte rappelez-vous qu'en 2005
les etats-unis ont vécu une crise
absolument majeur dont ils vont eu du
mal à ceux à se remettre c'est la crise
de katrina obsédé par le terrorisme
la fema qui est donc le truc qui vers
les urgences
aux etats-unis peu importe l'acronyme
est passé complètement à côté de
l'accompagnement des populations et la
nouvelle orléans a été sous les eaux
pendant des mois et des mois donc le
système de gestion de crise d america a
dû être complètement reconstruits
obsédé par le terrorisme ils ont été
incapable d'accompagner leur population
aujourd'hui est-ce que la fema et le
système de protection sociale mais de
santé américain est prêt pour
accompagner quelque chose qui est
complètement sourd aux injonctions du
président entre eux et ça c'est pas si
sûr de chance par la première c'est que
le paradoxe c'est que trump fait
baissent drastiquement les moyens sur la
fema sur la gestion des risques et dans
le même temps il dit world times ils
disent c'est la guerre contre le
coronavirus deuxième chose le parallèle
avec katrina est très important 2005
vous savez beaucoup de gens à katrina
qui ont dit à katrina à la nouvelle
orléans qui ont dit tous a été
enregistré on leur pose la question en
disant mais un cyclone s'est pas le
gouvernement fédéral mais ils disent
regardez on a détruit nos écoles
publiques
on a et c est ce qu'ils ont raison oui
en partie regarder ce qu'est en train de
se faire facebook amazon microsoft sont
en train de demander aux gens de rester
chez eux de faire du télétravail vous
avez des boîtes d'éducation à distance
aujourd'hui aux états unis qui disent
les écoles il faut les fermer on va
éduquer nos enfants à distance et voyez
il faut relire évidemment l'astra si la
stratégie sur la taille des polices qui
dit quoi
qui dit crise qui dit transformation
l'opinion et qui dit accélération de
politiques publiques on se prépare dans
mon monde du 21e siècle sans relation on
va voir comment ça se passe déjà dans
l'est dans les prochains jours et et
dans quelques minutes 1 où on surveille
l'élite est bien sûr on partira en
direct et dès que le président on
commencera à s'exprimer quel contraste
en ahl trump avec angela merkel carole
barjon angela merkel qui convoque très
très peu souvent la presse une fois par
an a fait une grande conférence de
presse dans laquelle elle a eu un
discours extrêmement froid actuels posés
en disant ils poussent le dire un peu la
churchill deux tiers des allemands
seront affectés discours de vérité
comment
vous analysez au fond ce contraste là je
trouve que angela merkel le prends les
choses de manière posée c'est ce qu'il
faut en temps de crise parce que le
problème de donald trump
c'est que c'est très gentil de dire
comme vous venez de lire la guerre aux
coronavirus mais aimer de piquant depuis
depuis avant-hier en fin d'hiver
au début ils ricanent et lie la ville a
même fait des remarques assez
désobligeantes pour les européens etc
donc il n'a absolument pas pris cette
crise au sérieux et le risque qu'il
court et on comprend d'ailleurs pourquoi
tout d'un coup il se rattrape de cette
manière
enfin très forte c'est parce que c'est
combien de crimes ans il est en campagne
et qu'il se rattrape parce que peut-être
que des américains pourraient lui
reprocher d'avoir sous-estimé l'ampleur
de la violence de ce virus puisque on
sait qu'il est extrêmement contagieux
effectivement qu est ce qu on a les
chiffres des deux nombres de lumière de
ce que vous voulez dire vous allez
rencontrer le conseiller de ben olsen
arrow il ya quelques jours dont vous
savez qu'il est testé positif donc
évidemment aux états unis qui se disent
voilà je reviens je reviens vers vous
parce qu'on a des chiffres qui nous
viennent de nous parvenir de la
direction de la santé comme le point
quotidien le fait il augmente de 1876
cas en france on vous dira combien de
plus par rapport à hier 61 morts
comment faites vous rappelez sur la même
période le nombre de décès sur âgées pas
le nombre de huit et douze mille
manières aussi du conte aura virus mais
les députés dans ce cas là à dire dans
l'un des morts du terrorisme parce qu'il
y en a beaucoup moins la société de
l'attention elle ne fonctionne pas comme
ça aujourd'hui
donc on ne peut pas prendre je la menace
de mort non campagne on s'y perd mais il
me semble qu emmanuel macron a dit il ya
très peu de temps il ya très peu de
temps on extension parce que l'épidémie
va bientôt partir à l'elysée j'ai une
question toute simple à dire par là
qu'il faut se poser il faut se poser
mais c'est vrai que pour l'instant la
france est toujours en phase dans stade
2 on est à la fin du stade 2 et tout le
monde a très bien compris qu'on allait
passer au stade 3 vous êtes communiquant
jacky isabello comment on fait pour dire
aux français on est en stade 3 et pour
autant il n'y a pas forcément un
changement énorme mais radicale dans le
quotidien l'instant les communautés
professionnelles médicales même si elles
sont pas complètement d'accord surtout
elles sont à la hauteur
le processus d' annonce de
l'augmentation de la courbe il est bien
géré on a des gens qui sont bien
identifiés en un un procureur molas de
la santé ça
sur les gens et là dessus les joueurs
français ont leurs forces dans leur
système de transfert je vous coupe 6
direction l'elysée on va écouter tout de
suite le président de la république
[Musique]
françaises français
mes chers compatriotes depuis quelques
semaines notre pays fait face à la
propagation d'un virus
le coc vide 19 qui a touché plusieurs
milliers de nos compatriotes
j'ai bien entendu ce soir avant toute
chose une pensée émue et chaleureuse
pour les familles et les proches de nos
victimes
cette épidémie qui affecte tous les
continents et frappe tous les pays
européens et la plus grave crise
sanitaire qui est connue la france
depuis un siècle
dans l'immense majorité des cas le
qu'ovide 19 et sans danger mais le virus
peut avoir des conséquences très graves
en particulier pour celles et ceux de
nos compatriotes qui sont âgés ou
affectés par des maladies chroniques
comme le diabète l'obésité ou le cancer
durant plusieurs semaines
nous avons préparé à j les personnels
des hôpitaux médecins infirmiers
ambulanciers les agents des samu de nos
hôpitaux les médecins de ville
l'ensemble des personnels du service
public de la santé en france sont
engagés avec dévouement et efficacité
si nous avons pu retarder la propagation
du virus et limiter les cas sévères
c'est grâce à eux
parce que tous ont répondu présent tous
ont accepté de prendre du temps sur leur
vie personnelle familiale pour notre
santé c'est pourquoi en votre nom
je tiens avant toute chose à exprimer ce
soir la reconnaissance de la nation à
ses héros en blouse blanche
ces milliers de femmes et d'hommes
admirable qui n'ont d'autre boussole que
le soin d'autres préoccupations que
l'humain notre bien-être notre vie tout
simplement
je veux aussi ce soir salués
le sang froid dont vous avez fait preuve
face à la propagation du virus
vous avez pu ressentir pour vous même
pour vos proches de l'inquiétude voire
de l' angoisse et c'est bien légitime
tous vous avez su faire face en ne
cédant ni à la colère ni à la panique
mieux en adoptant les bons gestes vous
avait ralenti la diffusion du virus et
ainsi permis à nos hôpitaux et nos
soignants de mieux se préparer c'est
cela une grande nation des femmes et des
hommes capables de placer l'intérêt
collectif au dessus de tout une
communauté humaine qui tient par des
valeurs la solidarité la fraternité
cependant mes chers compatriotes je vais
vous le dire ce soir avec beaucoup de
gravité de lucidité mais aussi la
volonté collective que nous adoptions la
bonne organisation
nous ne sommes qu'au début de cette
épidémie est partout en europe
elle s'accélère elle s'intensifie face à
cela la priorité absolue pour notre
nation sera notre santé je ne
transigerai sur rien et un principe nous
guide pour définir nos actions il nous
guide depuis le début pour anticiper
cette crise puis pour la gérer depuis
plusieurs semaines et il doit continuer
de le faire c'est la confiance dans la
science c'est d'écouter celles et ceux
qui savent les plus grands spécialistes
européens se sont exprimés ce matin dans
une publication importante
j'ai réuni aujourd'hui avec le premier
ministre le ministre de la santé
notre comité scientifique de suivi nous
avons en france les meilleurs virologues
les meilleurs épidémiologistes des
spécialistes de grand renom des
cliniciens aussi des gens qui sont sur
le terrain et que nous avons écouté
comme nous faisons depuis le premier
jour
tous nous ont dit que malgré nos efforts
pour le freiner le virus continue de se
propager et est en train de s'accélérer
nous le savions nous le redoutions ce
qui risque de se passer c'est que la
maladie touchera d'abord les personnes
les plus vulnérables
beaucoup d'entre eux auront besoin de
soins adaptés à l'hôpital souvent
d'assistance respiratoire
c'est pourquoi j'y reviendrai dans un
instant nous prenons des mesures très
fortes pour augmenter massivement nos
capacités d'accueil à l'hôpital car
l'enjeu est de continuer a aussi soigné
les autres maladies c'est aussi de se
préparer à une possible deuxième vague
qui touchera un peu plus tard en nombre
beaucoup plus réduit des personnes plus
jeunes
a priori moins exposés à la maladie mais
qu'il faudra soigner également dans ce
contexte
l'urgence est de protéger nos
compatriotes les plus vulnérables et
l'urgence est de freiner l'épidémie
afin de protéger nos hôpitaux nos
services d'urgence et de réanimation
nous soignons qui vont avoir à traiter
comme je viens de vous l'expliquer
de plus en plus de patients atteints ce
sont là nos priorités c'est pour cela
qu'il nous faut continuer de gagner du
temps et suivre celles et ceux qui sont
les plus fragiles protéger les plus
vulnérables
d'abord c'est la priorité absolue c'est
pourquoi je demande ce soir à toutes les
personnes âgées de plus de 70 ans à
celles et ceux qui souffrent de maladie
chronique ou de troubles respiratoires
aux personnes en situation de handicap
de rester autant que possible à leur
domicile elles pourront bien sûr sortir
de chez elle pour faire leurs courses
pour s'aérer
mais elles doivent limiter leurs
contacts au maximum dans ce contexte
j'ai interrogé les scientifiques sur nos
élections municipales dont le premier
tour se tiendra dans quelques jours
il considère que rien ne s'oppose à ce
que les français même les plus
vulnérables se rendent aux urnes
j'ai aussi demandé au premier ministre
il l'a fait encore ce matin de consulter
largement toutes les familles politiques
et elles ont exprimé la même volonté
mais il conviendra de veiller au respect
strict des gestes barrières contre le
virus et des recommandations sanitaires
je fais confiance au maire et au civisme
de chacun d'entre vous je sais aussi que
les mairies les services de l'état ont
bien organiser les choses
des consignes renforcées seront donnés
dès demain afin que nos aînés
n'attendent pas longtemps que des fils
ne se constitue pas que les distances
soit aussi tenu et que ces fameuses
mesures barrières soient bien respectées
mais il est important dans ce moment en
suivant l'avis des scientifiques comme
nous venons de le faire d'assurer la
continuité de notre vie démocratique et
de nos institutions
voilà la priorité des priorités
aujourd'hui et donc de protéger les plus
faibles
celles et ceux que cette épidémie touche
d'abord la deuxième c'est de freiner
l'épidémie
pourquoi ministre de la santé
le directeur général de la santé voulons
expliqué à plusieurs reprises pour
éviter l'accumulation de passion qui
seront en détresse respiratoire dans nos
services d'urgence et de réanimation
il faut continuer de gagner du temps et
pour cela je vais vous demander de
continuer à faire des sacrifices et
plutôt d'en faire davantage mais pour
notre intérêt collectif dès lundi et
jusqu'à nouvel ordre les crèches les
écoles les collèges les lycées et les
universités seront fermés pour une
raison simple nos enfants et nos plus
jeunes selon les scientifiques toujours
sont celles et ceux qui propagent
semble-t-il le plus rapidement le virus
même si pour les enfants ils n'ont
parfois pas de symptômes et heureusement
ne semble pas aujourd'hui
souffrir de formes aiguës de la maladie
c'est à la fois pour les protéger et
pour réduire la dissémination du virus à
travers notre territoire
service de garde sera mise en place
région par région nous nous trouverons
les bonne organisation pour que en effet
les personnels qui sont indispensables à
la gestion de la crise sanitaire puisse
faire garder leurs enfants et continuer
d'aller au travail pour vous protéger
vous soigner et donc cette organisation
sera travaillée par le gouvernement dans
les prochains jours avec l'ensemble des
élus et tous les responsables sur nos
territoires
quand cela est possible je demande aux
entreprises de permettre à leurs
employés de travailler à distance les
ministres l'ont déjà annoncé nous avons
beaucoup développer le télétravail
il faut continuer cela l'intensifier au
maximum les transports publics seront
maintenues car les arrêter
ce serait tout bloquer y compris la
possibilité de soigner mais là aussi
c'est à votre responsabilité que j'en
appelle et j'invite tous les français à
limiter leurs déplacements au strict
nécessaire
le gouvernement annoncera par ailleurs
des mesures pour limiter au maximum les
rassemblements dans le même temps notre
système de santé notamment dans les
services de réanimation doit se préparer
à accueillir de plus en plus de cas
graves de covile 19 et continuer à
soigner les autres malades des places
doivent se libérer dans les hôpitaux
pour cela toutes les capacités
hospitalières nationale ainsi que le
maximum de médecins et de soignants
seront mobilisés nous allons aussi
mobiliser les étudiants les jeunes
retraités des mesures exceptionnelles
seront prises en ce sens beaucoup
d'ailleurs
où commence et je veux les en remercier
j'ai vu il ya quelques jours au samu de
paris
mobilisation magnifique émouvante
exemplaires ou des étudiants à quelques
mois leur concours était là pour
répondre aux appels et des et où des
médecins à peine retraité était revenu
pour prêter main forte c'est cela que
nous allons collectivement généralisée
en prenant les bonnes mesures
en parallèle les soins non essentiels à
l'hôpital seront reportés c'est à dire
les opérations qui ne sont pas urgentes
tout ce qui peut nous aider à gagner du
temps la santé n'a pas de prix
le gouvernement mobilisera tous les
moyens financiers nécessaires pour
porter assistance pour prendre en charge
les malades pour sauver des vies quoi
qu'il en coûte
et beaucoup des décisions que nous
sommes en train de prendre beaucoup des
changements auxquels nous sommes en
train de procéder nous les garderons pas
ce que nous apprenons aussi de cette
crise parce que nous soignons sont
formidables d'innovation et de
mobilisation est ce que nous sommes en
train de fred en train de faire nous en
tirons toutes les leçons et sortiront
avec un système de santé encore plus
fort la mobilisation générale est
également celle de nos chercheurs de
nombreux programmes français et
européens essais cliniques sont en cours
pour produire en quantité des
diagnostics rapides performant et
efficace
nous allons améliorer les choses en la
matière et au niveau français comme
européen
les travaux sont lancés nos professeurs
avec l'appui des acteurs privés
travaillent d'ores et déjà sur plusieurs
pistes de traitements à paris marseille
lyon entre autres des protocoles ont
commencé et j'espère que dans les
prochaines semaines et prochains mois
nous aurons des premiers traitements que
nous pourrons généralisée l'europe a
tous les atouts pour offrir au monde
l'antidote au qu'ovide 19
des équipes sont également à pied
d'oeuvre pour inventer un vaccin
il ne pourra pas voir le jour avant
plusieurs mois mais il est porteur de
grands espoirs
la mobilisation de notre recherche
française européenne est aussi au rendez
vous et je continuerai l'intensifier
cette épreuve exige aussi une
mobilisation sociale envers les plus
démunis les plus fragiles la trêve
hivernale sera reportée de deux mois et
je demande au gouvernement des mesures
exceptionnelles dans ce contexte pour
les plus fragiles
enfin les preuves que nous traversons
exige une mobilisation générale sur le
plan économique
déjà des restaurateurs des commerçants
des artisans des hôteliers des
professionnels du tourisme de la culture
de l'événementiel du transport souffre
je le sais les entrepreneurs
s'inquiètent pour leurs carnets de
commande et tous vous vous interrogez
pour votre emploi pour votre pouvoir
d'achat je le sais c'est légitime et
avec les décisions que je viens
d'annoncer ce soir cette inquiétude
économique va évidemment s'accroître
nous n'ajouterons pas aux difficultés
sanitaires
la peur de la faillite pour les
entrepreneurs l'angoissent du chômage et
des fins de mois difficiles pour les
salariés aussi tout sera mis en oeuvre
pour protéger nos salariés et pour
protéger nos entreprises
quoi qu'il en coûte là aussi des les
jours à venir
un mécanisme exceptionnel et massif de
chômage partiel sera mise en oeuvre des
premières annonces ont été faites par
les ministres nous iront beaucoup plus
loin
l'état prendra en charge l'indemnisation
des salariés contraints à rester chez
eux
je veux en la matière que nous
inspirions de ce que les allemands ont
su par exemple mettre en oeuvre avec un
système plus généreux plus simple que le
nôtre
je veux que nous puissions préserver les
emplois et les compétences c'est-à-dire
faire en sorte que les salariés puissent
rester dans l'entreprise
même s'ils sont obligés de rester à la
maison et que nous les payons je veux
que nous puissions protéger aussi nos
indépendant et donc nous prendrons
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
donner cette garantie sur le plan
économique
toutes les entreprises qui le souhaitent
pourront reporter sans justification
sans formalité sans pénalité le paiement
des cotisations et impôts dus en mars
nous travaillerons ensuite sur les
mesures nécessaires ou d'annulation ou
de rééchelonnement mais genou koné
collectivement prend toujours trop de
temps à faire cela je veux pour nos
forces économiques des mesures simples
les échéances qui sont dus dans les
prochains jours et les prochaines
semaines seront suspendus pour toutes
celles et ceux qui en ont besoin
nous défendrons nos entreprises de
toutes tailles
nous défendrons l'ensemble des
travailleurs et des travailleuses
en parallèle j'ai demandé au
gouvernement de préparer d'ores et déjà
un plan de relance national et européen
cohérent avec nos priorités et nos
engagements pour l'avenir nous devons
aussi porter une réponse européenne
la banque centrale a déjà aujourd'hui
fait part de ses premières décisions
seront elles suffisantes je ne le crois
pas il lui appartiendra d'en prendre de
nouvelles mais je vais être là aussi
très clair avec vous ce soir nous
européens ne laisseront pas une crise
financière et économique se propage et
nous réagirons fort et nous réagirons
vite l'ensemble des gouvernements
européens doit prendre les décisions de
soutien de l'activité
puis de relance quoi qu'il en coûte la
france le fera et c'est cette ligne que
je porterai au niveau européen en votre
nom
c'est déjà ce que j'ai fait lors du
conseil exceptionnel qui s'est tenue
hier
je ne sais ce que les marchés financiers
donneront dans les prochains jours mais
je serai tout aussi clair l'europe
réagira de manière organisée massive
pour protéger son économie
je souhaite aussi que nous puissions
nous organiser sur le plan international
et j'en appelle à la responsabilité des
puissances du g7 et du g20
dès demain j'échangerais avec le
président trump pour lui proposer une
initiative exceptionnelle entre les
membres du g7
puisque c'est lui qui à la présidence ça
n'est pas la division qui permettra de
répondre à ce qui est aujourd'hui une
crise mondiale mais bien notre capacité
à voir juste et aux ensembles et à agir
ensemble
mes chers compatriotes
toutes ces mesures sont nécessaires pour
notre sécurité à tous et je vous demande
de faire bloc autour d'elle on ne vient
pas en effet à bout d'une crise d'une
telle ampleur sans faire bloc
on ne vient pas à bout d'une crise d'une
telle ampleur sans une grande discipline
individuelle et collective sans une
unité
j'entends aujourd'hui dans notre pays
des voies qui vont en tous sens certains
nous disent vous n'allez pas assez loin
et voudrait tous fermés et s'inquiète de
tout de manière parfois
disproportionnées et d'autres
considèrent que ce risque n'est pas pour
eux j'ai essayé de vous donner ce soir
ce qui doit être la ligne de notre
nation toute entière
nous devons aujourd'hui éviter deux
écueils mes chers compatriotes
d'une part le repli nationaliste ce
virus
il n'a pas de passeport il nous faut
unir nos forces coordonner nos réponses
coopérer la france est à pied d'oeuvre
la coordination européenne est essentiel
et j'y veillerai nous aurons sans doute
des mesures à prendre mais il faut les
prendre pour réduire les échanges entre
les zones qui sont touchées celles qui
ne le sont pas ce ne sont pas forcément
les frontières nationales
il ne faut céder là à aucune facilité
aucune panique
nous aurons sans doute des mesures de
contrôle des fermetures de frontière à
prendre mais il faudra les prendre quand
elles seront pertinentes et il faudra
les prendre en européen à l'échelle
européenne
ce car c'est à cette échelle là que nous
avons construit nos libertés et nos
protections
l'autre écueil ce serait le repli
individualiste
jamais de telles épreuves ne se surmonte
en solitaire c'est au contraire en
solidaire en disant nous plutôt qu'en
pensant jeu que nous relèverons cet
immense défi
c'est pourquoi je veux vous dire ce soir
que je compte sur vous pour les jours
les semaines les mois à venir
je compte sur vous parce que le
gouvernement ne peut pas tout seul et
parce que nous sommes une nation
chacun a son rôle à jouer je compte sur
vous pour respecter les consignes qu'ils
sont et seront donnés par les autorités
et en particulier ses fameux gestes
barrière contre le virus
elles sont aujourd'hui encore trop peu
appliquées
cela veut dire se laver les mains
suffisamment longtemps avec du savon ou
avec des gels hydro-alcooliques
cela veut dire salut et sans embrasser
ou serrer la main pour ne pas se
transmettre le virus
cela veut dire se tenir à distance d'un
mètre ces gestes ils peuvent vous à
paraître anodin il sauve des vies des
vies c'est pourquoi
chers compatriotes je vous appelle
solennellement à les adopter
chacun d'entre nous détient une part de
la protection des autres à commencer par
ses proches je compte sur vous aussi
pour prendre soin des plus vulnérables
de nos compatriotes ne pas rendre visite
à nos aînés sait et j'en ai bien
conscience
un crève coeur c'est pourtant nécessaire
temporairement écrivait téléphoner
prenez des nouvelles protéger en
limitant les visites
je compte sur vous oui pour aussi aidé
le voisin qui lorsqu'il est personnel
soignant a besoin d'une solution de
garde pour ses enfants pour aller
travailler et s'occuper des autres
je compte sur les entreprises pour aider
tous les salariés qui peuvent travailler
chez eux à le faire je compte sur nous
tous pour inventer dans cette période de
nouvelles solidarités
je demande à ce titre au gouvernement de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
avec les associations dans cette
direction cette crise doit être
l'occasion d'une mobilisation nationale
de solidarité entre générations nous en
avons les ressorts il ya déjà des
actions qui existent sur le terrain nous
pouvons faire encore plus fort
tous ensemble
je compte évidemment aussi surtout nos
soignants je sais tout ce qu'ils ont
déjà fait je sais ce qu'il leur reste à
faire
le gouvernement et moi-même serons là
nous prendrons toutes nos
responsabilités pour vous je pense à
tous nos soignants à l'hôpital qui
auront les cas les plus graves à traiter
mais aussi beaucoup d'urgences je pense
aux médecins et aux infirmiers aux
infirmières à tous les soignants qui
sont aussi hors de l'hôpital qui se sont
formidablement mobilisé que nous allons
de plus en plus sollicitée dans les
semaines à venir
je sais pouvoir compter sur vous le
ministre de la santé aura l'occasion
aussi de préciser dans les prochaines
heures
les règles pour que nous vous aidions à
bien vous protéger contre le virus
c'est le respect que nous avons envers
vous et c'est évidemment ce que la
nation vous dois les règles seront
claires pour chacun
elles seront là aussi proportionnée et
expliqué je compte sur vous toutes et
tous pour faire nation au fond pour
réveiller ce qu'il y a de meilleur en
nous pour révéler cette âme généreuse
qui par le passé a permis à la france
d'affronter les plus dures épreuves
mes chers compatriotes il nous faudra
demain tirer les leçons du moment que
nous traversons interrogé le modèle de
développement dans lequel s'est engagé
notre monde depuis des décennies et qui
dévoile ces failles au grand jour
interrogés les faiblesses de nos
démocraties ce que révèle d'ores et déjà
cette pandémie
c'est que la santé gratuite sans
conditions de revenus de parcours ou de
profession notre état providence ne sont
pas des coûts ou des charges mais des
biens précieux des atouts indispensables
quand le destin frappe
ce que révèle cette pandémie c'est qu'il
ait des biens et des services qui
doivent être placés en dehors des lois
du marché délégué notre alimentation
notre protection notre capacité à
soigner notre cadre de vie au fond à
d'autres est une folie nous devons en
reprendre le contrôle
construire plus encore que nous ne le
faisons déjà une france et une europe
souveraine une france et une europe qui
tiennent fermement leur destin en main
les prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois
nécessiteront des décisions de rupture
en ce sens je les assumerai mais le
temps aujourd'hui est à la protection de
nos concitoyens et à la cohésion de la
nation
le temps est à cette union sacrée qui
consiste à suivre tous ensemble un même
chemin à ne céder à aucune panique
aucune peur à aucune facilité et à
retrouver cette force d'âme qui est la
nôtre et qui a permis à notre peuple de
surmonter temps de crise à travers
l'histoire la france unie c'est notre
meilleur atout dans la période troublée
que nous traversons nous tiendrons tous
ensemble vive la république vive la
france
et voilà donc pour et voilà donc pour
cette allocution du président de la
république un peu plus longue que prévu
26 minutes très précisément le chef de
l'état qui appelle à la mobilisation
générale de l'ensemble de la nation nous
sommes toujours avec bruno questel
député la république je marche de leur
judith waintraub qui est grand reporter
au figaro magazine
carole barjon qui est éditorialiste à
l'ops et jacky isabello communicants
cofondateur de koryo link je me tourne
tout de suite vers le député que vous
êtes de la majorité il ya une grande
mesure très forte qui n'était pas
forcément attendu c'est la fermeture de
l'ensemble des établissements scolaires
est ce qu'elle est de nature à rassurer
un pays inquiet et a mené cette bataille
contre cette épidémie la mesure que vous
attirez que vous attendiez tous étaient
le report des élections municipales je
comprends la déception
maintenant il le dit lui même j'ai posé
la question on m'a dit non le simple
fait qu'il pose la question dans l'après
midi avec le mécanisme médiatique et
politique parisien fait que toutes les
rédactions sont informés qu'ils aient
posé la question donc toutes les
rédactions part du principe que les
élections vont annuler
c'est pas le cas c'est déjà quelque
chose après sur les haies sur les écoles
et les crèches
oui il a pas donné limite de temps
d'ailleurs vous l'avez remarqué l'année
jusqu'à nouvel ordre jusqu'à nouvel
ordre sa peutrec ou aussi donc ça veut
dire aussi que on va poser les choses
sereinement sereinement tant qu en
dehors de beauce est arrivé là oui moi
je suis j'ai été maire longtemps je suis
je suis venu vous voir et me vient de ma
commune de 4000 habitants dont j'étais
mère près de 17 ans et je puis vous dire
que oui
les françaises et les français sont en
attente de mesures concrètes donc là on
va leur dire bah non pendant quelques
jours il n'ya pas y'a pas de possibilité
et après les choses vont se dérouler les
de l'europe
non comment vous l'avez trouvé le
président d'un public a été très attendu
c'est la première fois qu'il s'adresse
aux français depuis le début de cette
crise j'ai trouvé que l'ampleur de son
message était très importante il ne
s'est pas contenté d'annoncer des
mesures immédiates non report des
municipales ou alors fermeture de tout
système scolaire avec l'éclat à crêches
les universités ou conseil demande aux
personnes âgées de 70 ans et plus de
nous pas sortir de chez elles sauf pour
le strict nécessaire
sur le plan économique il est allé je
pense un peu au delà de ce qu'espérait
les entreprises qui souffrent quelle que
soit la réponse est un non massif de
soutien une suppression d'une
substitution
encore pardon des cotisations des impôts
dus pour le mois de mars on verra s'il
le reconduit ou pas ce qui veut dire que
l'objectif de rester dans les clous de
maastricht est officiellement abandonné
aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'on s'assoit
sur la règle c'est pas qu'on s'assoit on
considère que c'est madame viséo conseil
considère que l'urgence nécessite de les
abandonner
mais emmanuel macron voir encore pu voir
puisque il promet des ruptures après la
crise dans notre développement
économique dans notre modèle économique
il veut restaurer la souveraineté
française et européenne c'est là qu'il a
certes beaucoup de politique totale
nouveauté c'est l'exigence à leur
conscience fardeau que je dis qu'il est
allé plus loin qu'une simple
intervention de crise
il avait compris comme ça ou c'est
carole complètement c'est extrêmement
intéressant moi c'est ce qui m'a le plus
intéressé d'ailleurs parce que
effectivement il va déjà il se projette
en disant voilà au fond c'est la loi du
marché qui est un peu qui est en
question
alors on sait bien qu'on n'est pas dans
la loi du marché pur et dur en france
mais tout de même
c'était intéressant pour quelqu'un qui a
été quand même présenté en 2017
souvenez-vous pendant sa campagne
électorale comme un vrai libéral la non
non non et andré européen c'est vous qui
représentez non non non c'était comme ça
qu'ils étaient perçus deux mais ça c'est
pas des communistes vous avez
souverainiste non il n'est pas dit que
les livres du modèle tout finit là là il
est immense et un c'est quand même
changement à dévoyer radical le début de
l'acte 2 du quinquennat pour la suite je
croyais qu'on y était déjà donc moi je
dirais que ce croissant de la batterie
directement
c'est intéressant excusez moi mais
excusez moi monsieur mes deux secondes
moi j'ai juste un petit truc je suis
confronté régulièrement au suffrage
universel
c'est quand les françaises et les
français vont mettre un bulletin dans
une enveloppe et dans une urne vous
faites vos commentaires en 10 ans on est
déjà à l'acte iii à l'acte iv à l'acte 5
on s'en fout excusez moi mesdames mais
mais mais le sujet c'est quand même on a
une pandémie parce qu'il faut appeler un
chat un chat
on a un prétend de la république qui
s'expriment et qui dit des choses cette
dame et prix extraordinaire pas d'amis
ici non juifs à 26,6 juste un moment à
un moment il faut sorte c'est vous qui
ramené l'expression du président de la
république au débat politicien mais
c'est sympa politicien est libre d'avoir
ses commentaires et des élus on a comme
unique en effet le 60 m la française
sujet politiciens non non c'était vous
plaît j'aimerais qu'on termine ce tour
de table on a peu de temps pour
débriefer réutilisable est loin de ça
vous gêne
est-ce que les 3% de déficit d'imposer
par maastricht de ces politiciens
politique des fonds moi j'étais chez
jacky isabello imeda mais que votre
réaction sur ce elle confie je suis un
terreau
donc rassurez vous je me sent flatté non
moi j'ai ce que je partage sur le fond
sur la forme
sur la forme j'ai trouvé ça beaucoup
trop long mais toute façon le président
ne s'est pas fait recours
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un thème qui
était assez présent tout au long des
différents sujets et grave de sujets
qu'il a évoquée c'est ce fameux concept
du devoir de vigilance qui est très fort
chez lui qui a été beaucoup commentée
puisque vous savez qu'en france on a
l'habitude de demander à l'état de tout
faire et là tout au long de son
intervention il a vraiment
responsabiliser les gens il leur a
demandé de faire attention il leur a
demandé de prendre je compte sur vous a
dit avant de prendre soin d eux des
soignants il a rappelé la solidarité de
ceux qui étaient à la retraite est qui
et qui reviendraient donc cet aspect
très important qui a été beaucoup
discuté il va profiter toutes les étapes
de son discours pour le remettre en
avant et c'est vrai que d'un point de
vue de la préservation de
de notre santé sanitaire c'est un point
c'est important au-delà de tous deux
laitages allégés autour de l'individu
pour la solidarité compter sur chacun
mais le retour de l'état via s'ils
frappent aussi dans ce discours d'un mot
vous êtes d'accord avec l'analyse
bien évidemment c'est le retour de
l'état c'est le retour du président de
la république
la pierre angulaire des institutions et
du fonctionnement normal d'un état
républicain maire d'avoir sa
légitimation du dépenses publiques
fortes
oui on va voir comment justement tout
cela se traduit très concrètement dans
les jours qui viennent il va y avoir des
mesures
voilà sur le terrain pour trouver des
moyens pour les pour les enfants d'être
accueillis chez eux tout ça ça va
demander évidemment d'être suivie de
près et puis à terme le retour de l'état
et la dépense publique tout ça on le
suivra sur lcp merci infiniment d'être
venu débriefer en direct l'allocution du
président de la république très belle
soirée à vous et à demain
[Musique]